[Musique]
les caps a mis si déjà on compare nos
amis les quatre amis vous diront les
objets de la vie si tous kankan et
astucieux
vanille
le plus sérieux les gars ça me va vite à
jouer il suffit de vouloir devenir un
ami
[Musique]
bonjour fabrice bonjour ça va bien
fx qu'est-ce qui se passe 1 qu'est ce
qu'ils pensent à quel point notre
demande
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant et
parce que nous allons faire c'est
d'abord dire bonjour à tous nos amis oui
bonjour les amis
voilà voilà ensuite le jeu de la
géographie wailly nous allons réviser le
contour le contour du pays son drapeau
et bonjour dans la langue du pays
oui et puis et puis après on verra on
fera la suite de l'émission un banc très
bien alors je commençais tu le veux bien
par le contour du pays salazar tôt
géographiques où le capital est ici
c'est pas la capitale de ce pays est là
bien si oui ça c'est un set c'est un
pays qui n'est pas au bord de la mer
c'est à noter ce doit être un pays
d'europe centrale ça je pense peut-être
c'est bien vous voir le drapeau pour
salants voir le dren oui voilà ce
drapeau a une forme assez particulière
qui doit vous permettre de le
reconnaître aisément même si vous n'avez
pas la couleur
je signerais tout de même que ici nous
avons le bleu ici le blanc est ici le
rouge
bon si beaucoup de bleu blanc rouge dans
les drapeaux a souvent très ouvert mais
c'est vrai très souvent nous avons ça et
alors là nous avons le bon jour dans la
langue du pays
seulement il ferait savoir exactement de
quelle langue il s'agit je pense se
bride aux brides yen carry diel de
bridgend aubry dire oui ce doit être
écoute si chimiques tu veux dire qu'elle
vaut demande pardon oui il y as je suis
moi même de ce pays et il y a une petite
faute d'orthographe
ah bon à d'oubli amis chez y dans notre
langue
pardon pardonnez-moi à y d'agglos de
business de rieden bei viennent si je ne
trompe pas ne s'agirait-il pas de la
tchécoslovaquie à des grands drapeaux la
capitale et prague et je pense que il
s'agit là de la langue tchèque
voilà d'aubry tiennent pas ce qu'il y a
deux langues parlées si même un homme
tronc part dans ce pays
comme son nom l'indiqué doit y avoir le
tchèque et le slovaque
voilà de la bri dans le même pays voilà
fabrice tu es encore le plus fort c'est
ma mémoire tu avais une bonne marque l'a
vu chez qu'ai-je cargo qui a voulu me
ridiculiser en tous les cas il nous a
rendu service car il est secouru à vue
photographiées le lui ai même pas
répondu 1 tu alors tu sors balajo
restored je vais retrouver les autres un
bac oui mais dont le jeudi oui du point
commun puis on t'attend tu toujours
henry n'a pas écouté j'ai tellement à
faire là j'arrive
bon je suis prêt aux nappes et fabrice
rey fabrice voilà voilà voilà
viens t'asseoir j'arrive mais j'ai pas
envie de me fatiguer beau coin attention
que ce ne soit pas trop difficile chez
oddo oui enfin on avait déjà dit ça le
point comment rappelle tout de même un
toucan belles belles et pousse moussu
bonjour toi peut parler depuis non non
non non non les laisse parler les
grandes personnes allant à londres ce
sont 130 tout à l'heure des objets ou
des choses tout le problème consiste à
savoir quel est le point commun qui les
unit voilà je vous écris ce tient bon et
bien leur - fabrice je suis allé à
droite très apprécié des automobilistes
oui il me rencontrer souvent au cours de
leur randonnée d'ailleurs aussi bien sur
les autoroutes d'ailleurs que sur les
nationales et je suis un peu plus rare
sur les petites routes de campagne ça
c'est vrai mais on ne me rencontrent
aussi à la sortie ou à la rentrée des
petits villages et je m'arrange toujours
pour qu'on aperçoit de loin parce que je
sais que ça fait plaisir aux conducteurs
de découvrir ma silhouette au bout d'une
longue ligne droite tu vois d'abord je
leur procure de quoi tu continuer le
voyage les rassure sur l'état de leur
voiture et puis j'ai souvent quelques
petites choses à offrir aux enfants pour
les distraire un mais je me tais je
m'étais parce que je crois que j'en ai
assez dit
les un petit peu alors moi fabrice tu
m'écoutes au début je dois dire qu'il me
regarde pas et si je tort alors j'ai
représenté vacances aussi bien les
vacances d'été que les vacances d'hiver
je ressemble eu beaucoup de monde autour
de moi et je m'arrange toujours pour
avoir tout ce qu'il faut pour les
distraire en hiver on trouve chez moi
tout ce qui est nécessaire pour goûter
aux plaisirs de la neige des skis drôme
aux potes du petit chalet des moniteurs
ont été sur les plages
je vous propose des promenades en mer
des planches aval des pédalos des
concours de châteaux de sable des
emplacements pour voto tvo caravanes et
des parts de jeux sur la plage avec des
portiques des ballons de la pêche sous
marine à la g unit des jeunes idée mais
je préfère écouter maintenant la version
2 pouces conçu pour être sûr de moi même
ouais moi je vais te dire je suis pas
comme tout comprendre pas très utile
pour ceux qui voyagent
mais si si au contraire je suis je suis
très utile pour ceux qui voyagent mais
pas en voiture et non non je préfère
voyager en train on m'utilise aussi pour
pour les voyages en métro mais des
métros 1 y en a pas partout
alors ben j'aime mieux pas en parler
mais pour en revenir au train et bien si
je n'existais pas on ne pourrait pas le
prendre le train là si on avait réussi à
le prendre attention si on avait réussi
à le prendre on ne pourrait plus
redescendre et on voyagera erré toute sa
vie et puis ce serait enfin ce serait
très triste quand même j'aurais pu le
chef de gare déjà un peu plus de
passages souterrains
oui on est j'aurais que derrag drague
encore dire avec toujours des rails je
veux dire je crois voir je crois voir à
mon avis à mon avis tout quand on nous a
parlé d'une station-service belle belle
nous a parlé d'une station de sportive
elle a exactement et bouge moussu d'une
station de chemin de fer vous êtes donc
tous les trois des stations est
astucieux c'est après agressé très bon
vieux c'est bien bravo mon cher fabrice
a tout de suite et j'espère que tu seras
aussi très astucieux avec moi pour le
jeu des notes musicales aura que plus
belle en tout cas on prépare le jem jeu
ça vous fait mes adieux potter 6 coups
sous le soleil c'est à nous maintenant
c'est que ça va être à toi c'est notre
jeu fabrice tu as bien travaillé
oui oui je crois je crois que je vais
t'étonner la vraie ah oui je vais
t'étonner par contre une question c'est
très difficile et maintenant c'est pas
près dé finale tu verras tu crois que je
vais m'en sortir
oui oui très bien où tu t'en sors
toujours très bien dans mon crayon à
j'espère que tu n'as pas oublié
alors je veux câblo tu vas au tableau et
que tu me repose
eh bien je te propose un mot en huile
être hui les trois premières lettres la
la la première lettre
c'est un air air alors un deux trois
quatre cinq six sus dernière lettre est
la dernière à eux
alors est ce que c'est un animal
ah non c'est pas un animal est ce que
c'est une plante
oui c'est une plante tu vois tu as
trouvé est ce que c'est une plante qui
sent bon mais bon tu peux pas
spécialement m'enfin est ce que c'est
une plante qui
il se mange ben oui et non c'est à dire
que oui ça se mange jamais tant que ça
se mange à sa faim
oui ça va ça avait une certaine partie
se mange tu vois est ce que c'est une
plante que l'on trouve dans l'eau peut
assez facilement oui aux rires oui on a
un peu partout pas dans la forêt dans
les champs et dans les champs donne moi
une lettre tu vas encore une lettre ont
dit non alors qu'est ce que je pourrais
te donner veux tu là voyons voyons
voyons là la deuxième la wii la deuxième
elle est la deuxième après le 1er la
deuxième oui est ce que c'est c'est un
put à une 1ère sûrs u11 et rue je peux
encore donner un petit élément vas-y
avec cette plante on fait des compotes
et de la confiture et les petits enfants
aiment beaucoup ça avec et re oui avec
un rhume de la compote à des confitures
et oui dans ce propos c'est là si c'est
possible pour son esprit un tu n'aurais
pas écrit rhubarbe air rue mais chi
rhubarbe
bah oui la cndc rue hb à rb un jeu sera
toujours le désespoir de ceux qui
connaissent l'orthographe armes et
pourtant je croyais bien tu mets rh eu
un bon gars quand même 1 h jeu c'est moi
qui avais un navet ou hamza et palmer à
bâgé pas de chance et secouru barbe
voilà comment ça s'écrit rhubarbe
non vraiment est ce que je trouve
navrant c'est que tout cancan depuis le
temps witt incapable de te donner le
moindre coup de main il ne révise pas il
ne connaît pas mieux en parce que toi et
c'est pas bon tout cas
après un week-end ce que tu ne peux pas
tout savoir savoir mais regarde parce
que celles en tout cas ce que je sais
c'est que la rhubarbe c'est une drôle de
plante
oui parce que les tiges justement je te
disais tout à l'heure les tiges
elles sont très bonnes mais les feuilles
elles sont très très mauvaise et mêmes
et elles rendent malade voire bon alors
il faut faire très attention quand on la
prépare
il faut enlever toutes les feuilles tu
vois c'est exact oui bon ben je te
remercie de ces précisions tu ne
rattrape toujours un petit peu a été
fautes d'orthographe
ce qui est bien mais enfin tu sais tout
de même et tu dis un peu aigri et mal
sinon belle belle ne sera pas contente
bel bel sil top mais je suis prête
yutaka la slovaquie ce qui a joué avec
moi c'est pas si la musique de samassa
dont la façade a les mains sales
mensonges
c'était très tôt qu'à l'habitude alors
on commence quand on est bon oui je veux
je compte suis un peu énervé j'ai une
nouvelle intéressante à prendre oui oui
je prends des cours d'histoire à j'ai
envie d'apprendre un vrai métier je sais
bien que ça va te paraître étonnant de
la part de quelqu'un comme moi qui
connais déjà tellement de choses et dont
la nuit a eu tellement de réussite alors
réussite
oui réussi ça mais la première répète un
peu ce que tu m'avais bien j une mine
très charmant une amie non une usine
une réunion est une famille
c'est une famille et patton je vend de
tout dans cette famille un oncle par
exemple que pêcheur sur un chan y est et
puis qui a trouvé ce sera quoi
il est pêcheur sur un chacun y est à tu
veux parler de la lettre u cha lui et
ses plages et l'ancien dod exactement au
dock est lui aussi un cousin pons
tionnaires un cousin missionnaire oui il
aller prêcher la bonne parole aux quatre
coins du monde
ah je trouve c'est un fonctionnaire
alice young valent un missionnaire
j'aurais aimé surtout c'est que mon
arrière grand père architecte
à l'époque on construisait en pierre
parent tenant n'est pas intéressant le
moment pour les maisons
ça revienne pas c'est le oui c'est
dégoûtant d'ailleurs seulement c'est
dégoûtant c'est très laid c'est le froid
le maudit dont celle c'est de s'y rendre
le ciment il se dit la vérité
oui mais c'est pas bon pour lui d'aller
retour dans cette maison que je ferai
construire en pire j'aurai une grande
pièce qui servirait de salon et de sa
peut manger au bond de 2,2 salle à
manger salle à manger et il l'a alors
qu'est ce qui en fait une manche
tu sais que tu fais des genoux
maintenant alors ça devient difficile à
et puis dans ma salle à manger j'aurai
une grande chope pour mener une une
chope ont mené une chaude le bout aulas
traîtresse et puis j'aurai des fenêtres
avec des petits carreaux et je leur
mettrais des petits lits dont rideau
examen et bien voilà c'est parfait on
affronte les avons joué nous avons été
très bien maintenant nous allons chanter
d'accord vous avez
les tapis sont déjà en copa des amis
l'erika sa mini vous diront ils secret
de la vie magie s'est désisté et g shock
sa défense
mais comme jenny patinoire il faudra
faire
attention les gars ça me sans
contrepartie sans rudy et 4
ça me souviens bien
[Musique]
oui
made in usa
guy vous invite à jouer aujourd'hui etc
si je vous vois venir à un ami il suffit
de vouloir devenir has amis
c'est vrai corps est fatigué
[Musique]